welcome back to las vegas now well
memorial day weekend is almost here and
what better way to celebrate than with
food smith's food and drugs the sponsors
of this segment give us a chicken ranch
kebab recipe to make this memorial day
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from
smiths memorial day is right around the
corner and we're making a wonderful
recipe that you can
break out your grill for that's grilling
season the memorial day is what kind of
kicks that off let's get out there and
cook some food outside a lot of these
great recipes that you can find from
your local smiths this one being
buffalo ranch chicken kebabs
tons and tons and tons of flavor in this
you're going to love it if you love
buffalo if you don't love buffalo then
just make ranch chicken but i love the
addition of the buffalo in there but
what we're going to do is marinate some
chicken i'm going to use sour cream you
could use
yogurt
you can use maybe some mayonnaise i
don't know if i go mayonnaise route but
at least go yogurt or sour cream add
some buffalo sauce to that and then a
whole packet of ranch seasoning um trust
me
you're gonna need this whole thing and
it adds tons of flavor to this chicken
okay
get that stirred and then normally you'd
marinate this for probably a couple of
hours maybe even overnight
i don't have that kind of time so what
i'm going to do is put it in here
give you the idea of the marinade and
then go from there all right so we'll
put that over there get our chicken in
there
and give it a good mix
and like i said normally you let this
sit for a while and get all that flavor
and let it all kind of incorporate but
because we don't have time
i am going to make some skewers get my
glove off here
got stuff flying everywhere okay so what
our
skewers consist of our chicken
and then we're going to go onion
red onion i love for this sort of thing
yeah making a mess of it don't worry
that you're getting making a mess with
everything because it's all going to
cook together and then bacon is going to
be the third item i love bacon because
it just gives that smokiness and a
secret with this bacon is it doesn't
look quite raw that's because i
microwaved it for 90 seconds
when you add bacon to a skewer sometimes
the bacon doesn't cook all the way and
so if you give it a good head start um
then by the time everything cooks it
will be crispy which is what we're
looking for so i'm gonna build these
skewers and then we'll get them on the
grill okay i'm getting the last of these
skewers built they're nice and heavy and
they're going to be fantastic have your
grill heated to about medium medium high
don't have it all the way up because you
want these to cook kind of slow we want
our chicken to get cooked all the way
through before
they burn i have this cool indoor grill
that i'm going to use
but cook them for like four or five
minutes per side flip it over cook the
other side
and
mainly you just want your chicken to be
done so if you're worried about it just
put a thermometer in there 160 degrees
so we'll cook these until that point
okay these have been cooking about four
or five minutes per side i got about 155
160 on my thermometer you can find these
thermometers at your local smiths
you can have pick up deliver those to
you actually if you wanted one at your
house
let me put these on a plate these are so
full of flavor they don't even need a
sauce i promise you you can find all
these ingredients at your local smiths
thank you so much for watching thank you
for shopping have a happy memorial day
bye bye everybody
thank you to smith's food and drug for
sponsoring this segment for more
information visit smithfoodanddrug.com
now over to you mercedes